mamma ho capito che vuoi biscotti ma non
mi ha scritto come li vuoi al distacco
al cioccolato alle mandorle ci sono
200.000 facciamo una cosa adesso rimane
online attivando tutte le foto dello
scaffale va bene e tu mi cerchi proprio
i biscotti che vuoi 20 grammi di grassi
saturi ma è veleno ma col cavolo che
prendo no va bene su 100 grammi di
prodotto 60 grammi di fibre eventi di
proteine come sta e oro permesso a volte
volte ladri in bagno se li mangia il
latte il latte scusi ne vorrebbe del
latte arrivo subito è ecco scusi i
biscotti i biscotti una tv no scusate
scusate ragazzi arrivo subito
ok che fa scattare un'altra destra si ok
scusate scusate ancora adesso giura che
non dimentica che le uova le uova è il
sì mi aspettavo scusate mi aspetto
grazie
no vabbè la coca cola edizione limitata
per il gay pride
la donna lo zenzero ma dove volevo da
troppo no lo sciroppo d'acero senza ceo
di tesco michele buono dobbiamo stare
sotto i quindici hanno stipendi di più
un cake e vuoi più un cake
si no quindi non vanno bene solo
cattivissimi li ho provati già e guarda
tesoro quelli vicino vi di quelli che
hanno il cartellino rosso che ho scritto
offerta quelle sono buonissimi sono 15
euro a 7 centesimi city li prendete il
freeticket signora di flynn via allora
jonio otterrei da 4 euro e 99
sì ci sono 10 centesimi di differenza a
10 centesimi
pensavo bastassero scusi scusi
gentilmente mi potrebbe prendere quei
piselli lì in alto
scusi ma non solo molto alta ma nella
botte piccola c'è sempre il vino buono
mi è caduta la forza che sbagliate
grazie ancora per i pisellini croccanti
6 da maledire spesso qui perché laddove
vista da è io abito proprio qui sopra
terzo piano scala c e società fortuna
scritto atomica bionda molto più cognome
poi miss pasta e una vaschetta di mucosa
sono queste lasagne
ah no no allora michele la parmigiana
cecè eccellente vero dentro ma non mio
nipote non lo può mangiare
e allora mi dia con gli occhi negli
occhi e li faccio col pomodoro
mi stavo dimenticando anche e 300 grammi
di gorgonzola e poi mi dà ancora veschi
fina piccoline di vitello tonnato scusi
scusi signora gentilmente siamo 15
persone in coda è qui da un ora o si dà
una mossa o va a comprare da un'altra
parte perché qui siamo supermercato è si
va veloci se no va al mercato sotto casa
la bancarella va bene e dai o no non ho
ragione vorrei due etti e mezzo di
prosciutto cotto tagliato molto molto
molto sottile grazie
signora sono due etti e 6 che falso
lascio no non lascia proprio un bel
niente perché se no di chi devo duetti e
sei adesso due etti e mezzo quindi
gentilmente procede a rimuovere le sette
decesso se poi volevo 75 grammi di
ricotta e rigorosamente di capra ceca
una domanda ma la provenienza di questa
capra penso italia signora e grazie
immaginavo fosse italiana el un turca
vorrei sapere da quale regione proviene
la capra e soprattutto che cosa ha
mangiato nelle 24 ore precedenti alla
mungitura signora guardi non lo so
proprio beh ma è inaccettabile
io cambio supermercato guardi è
inaccettabile venerato se la tenga pure